hey guys welcome back to another episode
of awesome build where today we're going
to be making a rubber mold and then
casting it using some casting resins so
first off what's the purpose in making
them whole well as you saw in some of my
past videos like where we stab Malcolm
in the eye with that pen and blood at a
squirt out and stuff I had to make a
prosthetic so I made a rigid mold using
plaster and then I could pour latex into
it
pull out the latex and then use that
prosthetic I basically did the same
thing when I had to build the
prosthetics for Doug when he did the
plant of the Apes review I sculpted the
features using some clay and then built
a box out of cardboard basically around
it and then pour it in my plaster so
that I could get my negative and then I
could pour my latex into this and that's
how I made the prosthetics for his
monkey mask so plaster molds or rigid
molds are great for that kind of process
where you're pouring something into it
that is flexible that you can pull out
but if you're going to be making
something that's rigid and going to stay
rigid and you want to duplicate it
silicone molds are a better option but
when you're casting something or making
something that's rigid that can't bend
and stuff like that you want to make a
mold that's flexible or make a silicone
mold like this so in order to do that
today we're going to be using a product
by smooth-on called mumu 30 now there
are variety of different mold making
companies out there and you might be
able to find some at your local art
store but Blix definitely carries a
bunch of different mold making materials
and one of the more common ones that
you're going to find is by smooth on now
smooth line carries a lot of different
products that are great for beginners
and professionals so today we're just
going to be making a one part mold which
is just like this or these are just one
part molds with a two-part mold you have
two separate pieces that you can pour
your plastic into and then you have a
three dimensional copy of whatever it is
you want to make and for an upcoming
build we actually are going to be making
a two-part mold as part of the build so
I wanted to give you guys some kind of
an introduction into mold making before
we tackle that project so that's
basically today we're just going to keep
it simple and just make a one
our mold using the umma 30 and mostly
because the umma 30 is really easy to
use it's a one-to-one by volume ratio
which just means you have equal parts a
and B that you mix together to make your
mole so the type of mole we're going to
be making up today is what I call a
scrap mold and what that means is when I
am making a larger mold and I'm pouring
my resin plastics into it I generally
want to make sure that I have enough so
I usually make a little bit more than I
think I need so that I don't run out but
it cures very quickly and casting resins
aren't really that cheap and I would
rather not waste it so I create a series
of these scrap molds where I can pour
the excess resin plastic into it and let
it cure and then I have some of these
random parts and stuff like that that I
can use for other builds and other stuff
down the line like this one is just
simply a bunch of bolt heads and screw
heads and machine screws and stuff like
that I just took a bunch of bolts and
machine screws and push them into a
piece of clay I mixed up a rubber mold
poured it in and basically it fit like
this when it secured I could pull it out
and now I can pour my resin in there
when I have excess and then I have all
these little parts these different
machine screw heads and bolt heads and
stuff like that that I can use for
dressing up other things for instance
the spaceship corridor that we just
built a lot of those different paneling
and pieces and stuff like that a glue a
bunch of these plastic bolt heads and
machine screws to it it really gives it
a cool look and texture it makes it look
more industrial and you don't have to
waste real hardware this so essentially
that's what we're going to be doing
today we could be making just a another
scrap mold instead we're going to be
making a box using some scrap foam board
and we'll glue our objects down to it
make the box using some hot glue seal it
up so that it's sealed tight pour in our
mold and then give it about a day to
cure and then we're going to
open it up and see what we've got so
we're just going to be using a bunch of
these random scrap plastic pieces and
stuff like that
I've got like half of a wall anchor that
has an interesting shape and stuff like
that that's cool it's flat on one side
some different plastic pieces from toy
car or something or not even sure where
I got these but some sort of a end cap
or something like that alright but I've
got a few of these I think they have an
interesting look in shape and for some
of our future builds like their
spaceship or door and stuff like that
we're going to be making robot or gonna
be building model spaceships or and
stuff like that from scratch we'll have
all of these different kind of parts
that I can use very ambiguous and you
can use them for multiple applications
and they're flat on one side which makes
them ideal for a one part mold so we're
going to cut out a chunk of our foam
board here and we can glue our pieces on
to and then make our walls and now you
can use a little bit of hot glue or some
double-sided tape to kind of just glue
these down there probably use hot glue
for this one
I'm going to seal up all my edges so
then we pour
with with rubber into it doesn't seep
out make sure that you get all the
little stringy pieces out of there so
that they're not laying across any of
the pieces in your mold because the mold
will actually capture every single
surface detail alright now that we have
our box made and all of our pieces glued
into the bottom of it we're ready to mix
our rubber mold and pour it in
alright safety first make sure that when
you're handling the stuff you wear
gloves and eye protection to stuff up
so we have our Part A Part B container
to mix it in some mixing sticks I would
suggest if you guys are going to use
this stuff plan on using it all at once
once you open it up and even if you
don't mix it together but you just have
equal parts open you don't use
everything I would use it within the
next few days of when you open it
because it does not have a very long
shelf life at all so whatever your
project is I would try and make it so
that you're using all of the product up
at once or if you have like two separate
projects or something if you have two
smaller molds that you want to make then
do them at the same time or within a day
or two of each other because you don't
want to waste this stuff a box like this
cost roughly about twenty to twenty-five
dollars which isn't terribly expensive
but it's not super cheap either so today
we're going to be using all of it so I'm
just me pouring both these parts into
our container
you want to make sure you mix into you
of a solid color
these to make kind of like a purplish
bluish color you know on any marbling
we're going to pour it robots make sure
you put it into this one corner very
slowly
little self rumble
and then tap on the side of your box
before stop those air bubbles or banging
the table hanging on the table or
tapping on the side of the box get those
air bubbles to rise the tap because you
don't want them to affect the outcome of
your mold alright
so tomorrow we'll see what we've got
we'll pull our box apart pull our rubber
mold out and see what happens
all right so we've let it cure overnight
so now we're going to tear open our box
and see what we got yeah so I've got our
pieces here we can pull out of our mold
so now we're ready to mix and pour in
our resin plastic all right so what
we're going to be using is smooth-cast
325 it's again it's another 1/2 1 by
volume ratio of Parts A and B and so
it's super easy to use really easy to
mix up and stuff like that and the
reason what we're using the 325 is
because you can add pigment to it you
can add a colorant adding a little bit
of black to it if you don't have to add
any color into it you can just use it it
comes out kind of with like with a
little bit of a translucent to it but
then you can paint the surface any color
you want does really matter so all right
so let's start mixing all right don't
forget your gloves and your safety
goggles just in case there's any splash
you definitely wear gloves you want to
touch this stuff with your bare hands
till after it cures so again we're just
going to add equal parts of a and B into
some cups I'm going to add a little bit
of the colorant into Part B before we
mix and then once we mix it up into a
separate cup get a good mix going pour
it right into our mold and about 20
minutes to a half hour we should have
pretty good to your mold all right let's
do it
alright that looks pretty good to me
we'll give that some time to cure and
yeah and we'll pull it out of the mold
see what we got
all right let's take a look oh we get
pretty good
you
pretty cool exact reproductions of VAR
molds and actually I don't see any air
bubbles really or anything they came out
really well
you can see it matched up to theirs use
the original piece and there's the one
that we just made yeah so this will be
these will be nice parts then to add to
some other project if I need little
extra spare parts or whatever these will
be nice to have and as I said this will
be a nice kind of scrap mould that I can
use to pour some of my excess casting
material into when I'm making something
else once again I hope you guys found
this somewhat informative or
entertaining and I hope it inspires you
guys to go out and do some stuff with
your own make some molds make some
castings it's pretty cool it's pretty
fun when it all kind of comes together
and then you have these parts and stuff
like that
you can do it for you know scratch
building or model building and stuff
like that you can actually you know it's
kind of fun when you sculpt something
yourself and then you make a mold of it
and then you can pour and cast it and
then you can have duplicates of
something that you created which is
pretty cool once again guys thanks so
much for watching you guys are awesome
and don't forget to look me up on
Facebook at James Jim J Roz and yeah see
you next week we've got some cool stuff
planned for the future and as always you
guys Rock
see you next time
you